monsieur jean-paul chang bonjour merci
d'être en direct sur arte france la
fermeture du consulat chinois à houston
et qualifiée de provocation politique
par pékin est ce le cas selon vous je
sais pas si c'est une provocation ou il
yad'autres fondement derrière cette
décision américaine
il faut constater simplement que ce
geste place lignes allemandes et les
relations sino-américaines consume
logique d'escaladé d'escaladé important
faut savoir que c'est le plus vieux
consulat chinois est ouvert aux
états-unis houston
en plus c'est le symbole d'un voyage que
tout le monde de ce qu'on appelle encore
de celui d'apple sorti en 1979 aux états
unis avec son chapeau texan à l'époque
et tout est donc symboliquement c'est
très urgent est effectivement très mal
ressentie en chine et surtout ça les
oblige à prendre des mesures réciproques
donc on rentre dans une sorte d'
escalade alors quelles sont les
intentions mais bien etienne
en tout cas moi bien que vous avez passé
les images de mac pour bello appelant
donc à un front uni contre la chine
c'est effectivement revenir à une guerre
froide
cette fois-ci clairement et 2,2 de
remplacer les civils
le rôle de lurs de l'époque par par la
chine c'est précis et vous avez aussi
remarquer qu il s'agit d'une opposition
qui qu'ils soient idéologique puisque
mec qu'on peut on parler du parti
communiste chinois
mais en même temps c'est lui ferme des
consulats qui sont des représentations
de l'état
alors c'est faire fi finalement de la
réalité comme quoi le pratique mais ces
chinois finalement avec ses 92 millions
de manque en chine
en fait représentent les éléments de la
structure sociale en chine et faire
semblant de différence entre le
particulier
et la chine ça n'a pas de sens penser
disons que c'est une c'est une action en
tout cas unilatérale pour le moment très
très inquiétante
on approche des élections le moment et
on a l'impression que plus ça va plus on
va monter justement concernant sa
création d'une coalition mondiale pour
contrer la menace chinoise selon ahmad
pompéo ce sont de simples mots à vous un
argument de campagne pour pour soutenir
le président sortant donald trump ou
vraiment voilà le souhait de créer un
projet qui serait peut-être équivalent
record dont sanitaire qui entourait
l'urss pendant la guerre froide c'est
celui d'action bien sûr suivi d'actions
les américains ne sont pas restés
inactifs sur les différentes questions
qui touchent finalement l'arrêt pris
l'été les chinoises on l'a vu sur le
conte l'a vu récemment sur le soutien
sur le tibet et sur des web
de plus sa présence des porte avions
américain dans la mer de chine
méridionale coleman a répété donc en
fait il s'agit de il s'agit de l'homme
d'action très concret et les âmes états
cherchent à rallier effectivement
d'autres pays pour contrer effectivement
la chine on a l'impression que les
tenants d'une ligne dure l'ont emporté
dans l'administration américaine et que
en plus cela bénéficie d'un soutien
bipartisan pour le moment les autorités
chinoises manas washington de
représailles comment cela pourrait se
traduire dans les faits je pense qu'au
minimum niveau ils vont être forcés de
fermer un consultant américain mais il
faut savoir qu'il ya 100 consultants
américain en chine et 1 6 l'américain en
chine si on compte le consulat américain
l'euro kong
il faut savoir que bon c'est la valse
faire au presque automatique
or le parce que bon c'est lui
c'est du tac au tac dans ce genre de
bolloré ce que j'aimerais qu'un bon
continuer à affirmer notre consulat
situé en tout cas on est entré dans une
logique de d'escapades une escale à
qu'elle va continuer à mesure que les
élections américaines vont se rapprocher
en tout cas il est clair qu'aujourd'hui
ddv nistration fait en tout cas le vice
à son trend a besoin de thèmes très
mobilisateur bien vite son électorat
avec la situation de la pandémie aux
états unis et les critiques que la nhtsa
sont contraintes subies et ça se voit
dans les sondages sur sa gestion qu'on
avait réussi n'est clair qu'un thème
aussi fort et qui mobilise autant
d'attention joue en faveur
on a l'image d'un président fort qui
défend les intérêts américains
donc il faut parier que ça va pas
s'arrêter et le changement
d'administration tram s'est jamais
perdre et à l'action on pensait que cela
va calmer un petit peu c'est sa tension
sino américaines c'est toujours
difficile parce que je pense que les
relations sont difficiles à établir est
très facile à détruire l'histoire d'un
consul valkyrie stone c'est plusieurs
états américains où des citoyens et des
commerçants les businessmans s'ils
veulent faire des affaires en chine voir
difficultés à obtenir le visa la même
chose pour des chinois qui correspondent
aux états unis pour faire des affaires
c'est c'est tout est très difficile de
revenir en arrière donc même une
nouvelle administration ne peut pas
contenu de deux degrés d'échauffement de
l'opinion publique américaine en ces
temps ci contre la chine faire marche
arrière si facilement
donc certes ce sera peut-être moins
brutales ayant peut-être moins de
surprises il faut pas se faire
d'illusion cette cette façon de
considérer la chine comme un rival
stratégique mais qu'il faut contenir à
tout prix c'est un point de vue partagé
aux états unis entre démocrates et
républicains et quelquefois les
démocrates sont encore plus
l'excité contre la chine que le les
républicains merci beaucoup jean-paul
chance d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes économiste et
spécialiste de la chine